[Music]
straight ahead on law and crime daily
r kelly is back in federal court what
charges the disgraced singer now faces
out of illinois the deadly rush shooting
i would never point a gun at anyone to
pull a trigger at them never alec
baldwin says he did not pull the trigger
but does that match with the fbi's
investigation controversial author
salman rushdie is stabbed while speaking
at an event now his alleged attacker
faces serious charges and later two
former officers charged in the death of
george floyd are offered a plea deal
ahead of their state trial law and crime
daily covering court cases from coast to
coast
[Music]
and welcome everybody to law and crime
daily i'm brian ross in tonight for
brian buckmeyer we begin with r kelly
just weeks after a 30-year sentence was
handed down to kelly
jury selection begins in a separate
federal trial for the disgraced singer
the 55-year-old now convicted sex
offender faces 13 new federal charges in
illinois including receiving child
pornography enticing minors into illegal
sexual activity and obstruction of
justice
back in 2008 kelly was acquitted by a
cook county illinois jury for creating a
video of himself having sex with a 14
year old girl at the time the girl and
her parents denied involvement the
alleged victim refused to testify
federal prosecutors now say witnesses
and their families were threatened and
paid off in that case this time around
prosecutors say the alleged victim and
several other women allegedly victimized
by kelly will take the stand
kelly maintains his innocence and
pleaded not guilty to the charges his
former manager daryl mcveigh and former
employee milton brown will also stand
trial the trial is expected to last for
about four weeks last year kelly was
found guilty on nine counts of sex
trafficking and racketeering in a
separate federal trial back in june he
was sentenced to 30 years in prison by a
federal judge in brooklyn well joining
us now to talk about this our law and
crime legal analyst julie rettelman in
brooklyn and dr tracy pearson in los
angeles thank you both for being here dr
pearson let me start with you kelly was
just sentenced to 30 years in prison by
a federal judge in brooklyn why does he
now face a separate trial in illinois
well this is a case where
one trial begets another trial
the thrust of this case really is
obstruction of justice even though there
are five victims who
are
expected to testify and there are
charges related to
receiving and possessing child
pornography what we're looking at here
is his involvement in obstructing
the prior proceedings
where he was acquitted where there's
allegations that he paid off and
possibly instructed the victim to lie
and julia rettelman let me ask you this
in that trial kelly was tried and
acquitted as 2008 for creating this
video of an alleged child pornography
how is it he can be tried again on the
same charges what about double jeopardy
because it's really not double jeopardy
the evidence here is different the
evidence here is less about the actual
crime of the child pornography and more
of what he did to influence that
original trial and the argument is that
he tried to pay off and threaten
potential witnesses on that case and
that that's the reason that he walked
away with an acquittal um and so
therefore double jeopardy does not apply
and now we're going to hear potentially
from those witnesses who he allegedly
threatened um to see what they have to
say in terms of this obstruction and
tampering their testimony would be about
the alleged obstruction and the payoffs
that is exactly right all right julie dr
tracy pearson thank you stay with us
we'll get back to you in a bit in
california retired fire chief takes the
stand on day five of the kobe bryant
civil lawsuit vanessa bryant the wife of
the late basketball star brought the
suit against los angeles county after
officials allegedly shared photos of the
deadly helicopter crash that killed her
husband her daughter gianna and seven
others brian argues first responders
took graphic photos at the crash site
and then shared them with others outside
the police and fire departments long
crime west coast reporter megan cunhaff
was in the courtroom on monday when
retired fire chief captain brian jordan
testified kunif describes the testimony
as unbelievable saying jordan at one
point interrupted testimony calling for
a break in court
he was at the scene the day of the crash
took photos he's since retired from the
fire department he was basically forced
out forced into retirement over
controversy over the photos whether he
was told to take them whether he had any
purpose to take them he was combative on
the stand to say the least he was
his answers were
yes sir
yes sir very very much like that he he
denied even remembering being at the
craft scene he said he could not
remember any photos of the craft scene
couldn't remember taking any photos but
he does remember and he's very sure that
he was told to take photos
also in celebrity legal news amber heard
hires a new legal team as attorney
elaine bredhoff steps down redhoff head
of the team of attorneys who represented
herd in her defamation countersuit
against ex-husband johnny depp in june a
virginia jury largely sided with depp
awarding him 15 million dollars in
damages heard was awarded just two
million dollars for statements made by
depths attorney on monday first
amendment attorneys david axelrod and j
ward brown announced they will now
represent herd the pair recently made
headlines for successfully representing
the new york times in a lava soup
brought against them by former vice
presidential nominee sarah palin in a
statement heard's new team announced
plans to find a way to reverse the
judgment in herd's case
still ahead on long crime daily an
acclaimed controversial author is in
recovery after a stabbing attack leaves
him in critical condition
but first the deadly rust shooting what
fbi forensic testing reveals about the
prop turned murder weapon
[Music]
and welcome back forensic testing now
reveals the prop weapon used in the
deadly rust movie shooting could not
have been fired without the trigger
being pulled in october 2021 actor alec
baldwin held a prop weapon as he
rehearsed the scene for the movie in new
mexico the gun which was loaded it turns
out with live ammunition went off
cinematography helena hutchins was shot
and killed and director joel souza was
injured while no one has been criminally
charged in the shooting new mexico's
occupational health and safety bureau
fined the production company behind the
film over firearm safety violations
hutchins family also sued baldwin and
the movie's producers the fbi then
conducted an accidental discharge test
that determined the weapon could not
fire without the pull of a trigger
baldwin's attorney says the fbi's report
is being misconstrued and that the
weapon was in such poor condition proper
testing could not have been performed
all this comes months after baldwin told
abc's good morning america he never
pulled the trigger
it wasn't in the script for the trigger
to be pulled well the trigger wasn't
pulled i didn't pull the trigger so you
never pulled the trigger no no no no i
would never point a gun at anyone and
pull a trigger at them never
so julia redland baldwin maintains he
did not pull the trigger but the fbi
reports as a trigger had to be pulled
for it to go off what do we make of all
this
so many of us who followed especially
those of us who have tried these cases
involving weapons
had a hard time believing that the gun
went off by itself and so now we have at
least confirmation from investigators
that the gun did not go off by itself
and so when you ask yourself well who's
telling the truth there is there you
know obviously we don't know we haven't
heard ourselves from the investigators
but we have to say there's one person
who has the motive
to not tell us the truth or someone who
has an interest in potentially the
outcome of the case that's alec baldwin
that's not the investigators that are
investigating this case now regardless i
don't think anything's going to come of
it but certainly i think this weighs
against alec baldwin's statement that he
never pulled the trigger um you know in
order for the gun to fire well dr tracy
pearson let me ask you this following up
on julie said could the fb guy's newly
released report lead to charges for alec
baldwin particularly if he testified
under oath or told the fbi agents which
is a crime if you lied to the fbi
well i'm going to give you my favorite
lawyer answer and that is it depends
uh in this situation he may in fact have
believed he was telling the truth that
he didn't pull the trigger if there's
evidence that corroborates that he did
then in fact he may face charges for
lying to the fbi but more importantly
that fbi report is not yet out that
ballistics report is not public and i
want to be careful about characterizing
it one way or another because there is
some information to suggest that those
that the weapon could only be tested
once and that it broke in half because
it was in such poor condition but there
are folks that may in fact be looking at
potential charges here besides alec
baldwin certainly more to come on that
tracy and julie thank you so much in
california the reward for information in
the case of missing 16 year old kylie
rodney rises to 75 thousand dollars this
as the search continues a week after the
teenager disappeared rodney was last
seen at a party with hundreds of other
teens and young adults early last
saturday morning at a campground in the
northern part of the state sheriff's
officials say her 2013 honda crv is also
missing authorities say they've received
more than 1200 tips from the public one
of those tips fell flat this past
saturday when the fbi was investigating
a potential burial site and instead dug
up a dead dog officials have also
released photos of clothing rodney may
have been wearing the night she
disappeared including a hoodie with the
words odd future printed on it they also
say the last known ping from the teen
cell phone was around 12 30 in the
morning august 6 near our reservoir
surrounding the campground site
dive teams have been deployed to search
the area but so far they have not come
up with anything at all they are empty
authorities continue to urge anyone who
attended the party to come forward with
any new leads
we have one team
one mission
and one goal
and that is to find
sixteen-year-old kylie rodney we still
are urging people in the community who
may still be hesitant
you know you're not going to get in
trouble
all we want to know
is where is kylie
in other news attorneys for american
basketball player brittany griner file
an appeal following her nine-year prison
sentence in russia over drug charges
the phoenix mercury player and two-time
olympic medalist was arrested in
february at a moscow airport after vape
canisters containing cannabis oil were
found in her luggage griner was in
russia playing for a women's basketball
team during the wnba off-season she
pleaded guilty to the drug charges but
said she had no intention of breaking
any laws the trial continued despite the
guilty plea and griner testified in her
own defense saying she was in a rush
while packing and the cartridges ended
up in her bag a judge ultimately
sentenced her to nine years in prison
which some say is politically motivated
greiner's attorneys say in similar cases
defendants have received an average
sentence of about five years with a
third of them being granted parole
greiner has 10 days to appeal after she
was sentenced the grounds of the appeal
are not immediately clear
coming up on law and crime david will
two ex-minnesota police officers
involved in the death of george floyd
head to trial or accept a plea deal
plus investigators work to determine a
motive in the stabbing attack of author
salman rushdie
and welcome back iran now denies any
involvement in the stabbing of salman
rushdie as the controversial and
acclaimed american author recovers from
life-changing injuries
75-year-old author was set to give a
presentation at the chautauqua institute
in upstate new york last friday when a
man rushed the stage and began stabbing
him
staff and audience members later tackled
the suspect 24 year old haydee mater in
an effort to detain him barter was later
arrested and charged with attempted
murder and assault he appeared in court
over the weekend where he pleaded not
guilty to all charges right now martyr
is being held without bail as
authorities work to determine a motive
if convicted on both counts he faces
more than 30 years behind bars rusty's
family says the author was taken off a
ventilator this weekend good news but
remained in critical condition for stab
wounds in his neck and stomach as well
as puncture wounds to his eye chest and
thigh
rusty has faced death threats for
decades after his book the satanic
verses made waves in iran where some
considered it blasphemous against islam
dr tracy pearson martyr's public
defender says he has no history of any
violence or any past crimes were there
any warning signs they could have looked
for here
there is some reporting brian that uh
his mother uh observed some behaviors
that were concerning to her he had paid
a visit to lebanon to visit his father
that visit didn't go well apparently and
when he came back uh he his behavior had
changed he was no longer motivated and
he kept to himself he was very socially
isolated uh when we're looking at risks
we're looking at people whose behavior
changes over time it changes markedly
and that doesn't mean that they're going
to commit an act of violence what it
does is it offers an opportunity to ask
more questions it's better to say i'm
sorry and apologize than to offer
condolences
all right julie rudelman ruttermann
rushny received death threats for years
after the publication of that book a
fatwa put on him by the ayatollah it
even forced him into heidi at one point
i would know i've been at dinner parties
where he's complained about too much
security so how do officials determine
what threats to take seriously and how
could we learn from this attack do you
think julie
it's a great question with not an easy
answer um you know as tracy discussed
you know it's it's hard you know there
were signs but i'm not sure that there
were signs that he was going to
necessarily be violent towards this
individual one of the problems that
seems to be in place is you know they
spoke to people at the actual um event
who said that the only thing you weren't
allowed to bring in was food and drinks
so weapons were fine um and so it also
sounded like there was no security and
no one saw any visible security so
you know even the most minor protections
were not put in place and so it seems at
the minimum there should have been
something in place to prevent someone
from being able to come from the
audience with the weapon and attack him
the way they did but of course as you
know when it goes on for so long the the
person who needs the security gets tired
of it
yet no by the way you're absolutely
right and there there's a balance
between what he wants and what's safe
for everybody all right thank you so
much moving on now in florida door
barrio is unexpectedly canceled after a
weeks-long recess in the parkland school
shooting penalty phase trial the hearing
meant to determine whether an expert's
testimony is admissible in the trial was
expected to begin on monday that morning
defense attorneys notified the judge and
prosecutors they will not present issues
that were addressed in the dalbert
motions first filed by prosecutors judge
elizabeth sher set aside all week for
the hearing it was expected to touch on
the defendant's recent brain scans
defense attorneys originally said the
brain exam confirmed the gunman had
brain damage a status hearing is now
scheduled for tuesday afternoon this
comes after a week-long hiatus in the
death penalty trial where a broward
county jury will decide whether the
defendant receives life in prison or
sentenced to death on february 14 2018
the gunman opened fire at marjory
stoneman douglas high school 17 people
were killed and 17 more injured last
year the gunman pleaded guilty to all
charges
when we come back the death of george
floyd two ex-minnesota police officers
will head to trial this fall after they
reject a plea deal
[Music]
[Music]
you